[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce parc du mérou spéciale
le fait on va parler beaucoup de
bien-être de bien-être en entreprise
avec céline amyot fournisseuse de
bien-être en entreprise ou bonnaire en
entreprise bon nombre d'entreprises
tout un programme mais c'est vrai que le
bien-être en entreprise est quelque
chose d'important
on va parler de bien-être et de
gastronomie avec vous françois sauvaud
est la directrice générale du comptoir
du carrière d'abord on va parler de
technologie avec vos doigts dans le
temps de société x des motion même
marque et on vous le rappelez vous êtes
à l'origine de l'invention d'un robot
oui selon accents divers notamment pour
la télévision
oui tout à fait non pas devant quelques
fois et puis michael une vidéo qui est
avec son bébé 78 pc du sport parce que
c'est vrai que on peut bien manger un
petit peu près fait il me direz vous et
vos flops de l'année
tout est dans le programme c'est bon
c'est tout et tout est écrit tout était
gris encore ans maintenant ah non pas du
tout une donnée non non on va parler on
va parler que de bien on va peut-être
parlé avec françoise boisseau donc le
comptoir du caviar
alors il est dans les limites des murs
en face c'est un des sièges de votre
entreprise qui était d'une entreprise au
fond et dans le groupe il ya pas ivan iv
grand restaurant et il ya ce comptoir du
caviar sur l'impression que la cave hier
c'est quelque chose de extrêmement
luxueuse c'est vrai mais on peut quand
même se procurer
oui c'est un peu ça l'idée absolument
c'est tout à fait l'idée du content du
caviar
donc nous nous appartenons la famille
gardinier ou le vous le disiez don qui
est propriétaire d'effectivement de
prestigieuses établissements comme le
thaï van où les crayères les crayères à
reims et nous avons l'honneur de fournir
ces établissements donc néanmoins nous
notre histoire
elle est effectivement bien implanté
dans les yvelines dans ce petit village
de mule sens où nous avons une double
activité donc bien entendu nous appelons
comptoir du caviar donc notre métier
c'est d'aller chercher dans toutes les
fermes du monde du bon caviar
puisqu'aujourd'hui le caviar sauvage et
est interdite voilà on va plus voilà on
ne peut plus voilà aujourd'hui est
urgent urgent est une espèce lager
protéger donc et donc d'ailleurs nous en
tant qu'entreprise nous soutenons un
programme du wwf sur la préservation des
esturgeons sauvages qui ont été
finalement exterminés il en reste
il en reste mais très peu donc la pêche
est interdite depuis 2008
depuis 2008 définitivement donc il y
avait déjà des quotas et des choses
comme ça mais depuis 2008 c'est un délit
de pêcher de l'est sur jean la mer
caspienne qui était là elle est le
principal pourvoyeur de caviar dont a
été par don mais c'est quand on vous dit
hors du cadre des virus ou de caviar
d'iran et étaient donc les ombres
l'impression que c'est des caves et
rapidement nous dit non et bien écoutez
c'est illégal enfin voilà donc donc
aujourd'hui mais les grandes
on est d'accord voilà aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'il ya une certaine laure d'abord
le caviar c'est pas un produit connu et
c'est normal parce que ça demeure
effectivement un produit au l'exception
et de grand luxe dans tout le monde ne
mange pas du caviar tous les jours et il
est vrai qu'il n'ya pas eu de la part
aujourd'hui des acteurs du secteur une
grande pédagogie vis-à-vis des
consommateurs sur la réalité de la chose
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il a
effectivement le caviar c'est du caviar
d'élevage or il est pas moins bon mais
c'est du caviar d'élevage et certaines
maisons entre peuvent entretenir la
confusion effective de la confusion sur
l'annoncé alors il y à des élevages
aujourd'hui effectivement russie en iran
ça existe donc donc on espère que quand
on consomme du caviar wissous iranien
c'est bien du caviar d'élevage
voilà de la cité voix sur sur votre site
il ya plusieurs qu'il ya évidemment du
caviar d'aquitaine ou puisque c'est
seulement alors qu'il faut il affrontera
pourquoi l'équipe ncc tel parce qu'elle
plusieurs élevages en aquitaine
absolument donc aujourd'hui bon le
marché du caviar donc depuis plus de 20
ans aujourd'hui les cartes ont été
complètement redistribuées puisque
auparavant c'était effectivement la
caspienne donc la caspienne fourni c'est
donc via effectivement les russes et les
iraniens qui se partageaient la mer le
local ya aujourd'hui le principal
producteur de caviar au monde
ça étonne mais c'est la chine bon voilà
donc ça souvent on ne sait pas tout
simplement par là j'ai vu le reportage
l'autre jour sur le caviar chinois il ya
des il ya des sites internet
je veux dire des grandes quantités de
cavia pour les fêtes notamment et qui
essayent de vendre de casser les prix et
c'est du caviar chinois en effet voilà
bon après donc c'est vrai qu'il ya de
grosses quantités c'est le premier
producteur donc là dessus c'est comme
enfin c'est comme tous les produits à
boire et à manger
trivial
quand on dépense un peu d'argent parce
que même si j'ai vu avec vous avez vous
avez des choses on peut pour 25 ou de
trop tôt comme on peut s offrir des
caviars donc voilà c'est donc c'est
quand même assez accessible mais comment
c'est comment on peut savoir si on
achète de guéret un peu beaucoup de gens
vont sur internet peut-être si c'est du
bon pas du mot alors vous ne sais que
c'est une taylor nous voilà donc nous
notre engagement c'est quand même de
fournir de la qualité d'où notre maison
nous sommes une maison sérieuse ça fait
30 ans qu'on travaille dans le caviar à
destination des professionnels mais
maintenant à destination des
consommateurs comme vous et moi donc
tout neuf tout notre tout notre cas bien
toutes les provenances sont affichés
dont nous affichons non seulement le
pays d'origine mais également le la
ferme donc dans certains cas pouvaient
faire voilà la ferme dont vous achetez
un caviar d'aquitaine voilà donc vous
savez d'où nous travaillons également
avec une ferme chinois sur une certaine
variété des surgeons très précise qui
est un esturgeon né en chine donc qui
donne un très bon caviar et l'a donc
vous le savez c'est écrit sur la boîte
caviar du yunnan de la ferme amour donc
nous nous notre engagement en tant
qu'entreprise c'est vraiment d'être le
plus transparent possible vis-à-vis du
consommateur
donc ça c'est un premier engagement et
puis surtout va d'offrir un super
rapport qualité prix avec que du produit
de qualité et les prix que nous
pratiquons bon c
là un engagement de notre part pour
avoir des marges qui restent
raisonnables
voilà donc oui c'est ce que dit on peut
commencer les premiers prix sont
abordables s'est passé mais si je vous
dis que les premiers prix on est autour
de 1000 euros du kilo ça va pas vous
dire grand chose mais 1000 euros du kilo
ça veut dire qu'effectivement pour 20 g
20 grammes c'est pour deux personnes on
dit généralement il faut compter 10
grammes par personne pour une
dégustation donc 20 g bon ben voila vous
rentrez à la maison vous fait un petit
apéritif bio l'x et ça vous et vous vous
régalez enfin voilà donc la télé qu'il
est différent parce que le calvaire des
kits est non on l'avait vu ça coûtait un
peu moins c'est que quelques caviars
qu'on pouvait se procurer autrefois en
russie devrait revenir aux russes
c'est toujours un peu moins cher après
quand on regarde y'a le je crois que
c'est du béluga winga week end c'est des
prix mise à l'eau c'est quoi la
différence mots pour savoir quels sont
les différents de deux caviars alors
c'est lié à l'or donc c'est lié à la
durée
déjà il ya des des espèces de poissons
qui sont différentes donc le caviar
d'aquitaine c'est un esturgeon dit de
sibérie donc c'est un petit poisson et
ce petit poisson il faut l'élever cinq
ans environ avant de récolter le caviar
donc mathématiquement bon look aviaire
est moins cher par rapport à nos
assiettes re par exemple autres variétés
alors élevé 10 ou 12 ans donc il faut
nourrir les poissons dans tout ça ça a
un coût le béluga c'est un poisson qui
est énorme et qu'il faut élever minimum
une vingtaine d'années avant de pouvoir
récolter le milliard
alors on en trouve aujourd'hui un des
principaux élevage se trouve en bulgarie
donc une femme qui est spécialiste de ça
et qui a aidé notamment à repeupler le
danube donc il
il a un programme également sur
l'écologie qu'exactement donc il a pris
des sources ours souche excusez-moi de
béluga du danube pour faire l'élevage et
en contrepartie il donne également dans
des alevins pour repeupler repeupler le
danube en béluga bloquons pas c'est à la
fois la gastronomie et être d'avoir une
idée un d'idéal écologique coïtus de
contrepartie c'est-à-dire voilà c'est de
la défense nous nous on s'est engagé
aussi avec le wwf
parce que bon nous nous sommes négociant
nous ne sommes pas éleveur
donc voilà notre engagement c'est celui
ci met toute façon une filière scène une
filière qui fonctionne c'est tous les
maillons de la chaîne c'est de l'oeuf à
l'oeuf donc donc pour être sûr d'une
qualité produit à la fin dans votre
assiette
il faut aussi que la souche que
l'élevage etc de l'esturgeon voilà soit
soit soit bien pour donner derrière un
bon produit
enfin c'est la même logique que ce
soient des poissons ou pourquoi puisque
vous faites partie de luxe des bons il
ya du cav est un guerrier aussi
d'autres produits que vous vendez mais
il tarde à mal notamment vous êtes un
des grands spécialistes du tarn mais
alors vous il dit mais pourquoi ils font
pas de la truffe pourquoi il faut pas
d'eux des foies gras pourquoi vous
pourriez aussi celle des poissons déjà
alors voilà donc menacé d'y faire oui et
celui luxe d'une façon déjà mais après
bon après j'ai à chacun son métier il
vaut mieux d'ailleurs qu'elle peut de
choses et les faire bien voyez enfin
après ce sont des filières en face et
c'est tous des savoir-faire complètement
différent donc il ya un vrai savoir
faire dans le caviar aujourd'hui dans la
sélection du caviar pas trop ce que
j'essaie de là après il faut aussi en
nous on achète des grosses boîtes il
faut alors les reconditionner dans des
petites boîtes ça moi je sais c'est
parce que ça me semble qu'on voit à
l'écran ça c'est ce qui se passe à 1100
la gueule donc les personnes de notre
atelier qui font ça qu'ils remplissent
ensuite les boîtes avec la spatule
moi je vous mets au défi de le faire
parce que c'est compliqué mais ça
demande un vraiment un tour de main
savoir faire beaucoup d'entre eux
monsieur avoir fait une biopsie d'oeufs
d'esturgeon
ah voilà très bien papin pas facile à
faire facile
c'est vraiment tout un mythe sauf
peut-être au foyer de séjour du crif non
mais c'est un métier merveilleux
voilà il ya beaucoup de savoir faire aux
beaucoup de passion et beaucoup aussi
d'argent en jeu de la part des éleveurs
puisque va vous imaginez il faut élever
ses poissons vous n'êtes pas à l'abri du
risque de maladie de beaucoup de choses
et donc sa demande enfin c'est de la
passion et de la technique et vous vous
passez à l'heure de votre année les
voyager un peu partout pour les trouver
des fermes des esturgeons des plus
modestement fin des gens dont on
travaille déjà avec des fermes
partenaires et donc nous avons des
cahiers des charges assez précis sur le
le type de caviar que nous souhaitons
acheter
et voilà donc et puis on essaye
effectivement d'aller chercher des
caviars un peu un peu différent d'où
notre idée c'est vraiment de dire il
n'ya pas un caviar toucha caviar est
unique
donc aller chercher bien pâle meilleur
puisque chacun son goût mais mais
montrer la diversité du caviar desdits
fait des différentes variétés des
différents goûts promouvoir le travail
des fermes et surtout le rendre
accessible aujourd'hui aux consommateurs
pratiquant des prix qui soient justes
alors chez nous si vous allez dans la
boutique
bon c'est très simple le content du
caviar vers la madeleine n'a pas le
lustre en cristal enfin à bourg tout ça
c'est un comptoir mais bon nous notre
philosophie c'est plutôt de dire la
vérité c'est le produit c'est ce qu'il
ya dans l'assiette dans chez nous chez
vous vous le ramenez et puis on voit à
l'écran nous essayons de promouvoir des
modes de consommation simple le prier
parce que si vous devez attendre ben
d'enfin je sais pas le 50e anniversaire
de mariage aller dans un restaurant
étoilé cetera vous mangerez jamais de
caviar de voter alors que la bon vous
venez chez nous ou dans une autre maison
peu important mais voilà vous pouvez
acheter une boîte de caviar nom vous dit
balla par exemple vous pouvez faire des
coquillettes au caviar et au crack
magnifique ça c'est génial ne pas viser
d'abord ça c'est génial et des normes de
cash exactement donc les coquillettes on
en a voilà vous rappellera zeste de
citron vert un peu de ciboulette mettez
du crabe
si vous en avez vous réhaussé ça d'une
belle dune belle cuillère de caviar
c'est la fête au passé avec une bonne
bouteille vous passez une soirée un
dîner d'exception
j'ai des questions on a vu en quelques
années la démocratisation d'un certain
nombre de produits pour son foie gras
foie gras il ya ya 30 40 ans manger deux
fois par an mais non non non je me
conduisent le saumon est ce que vous
pensez que ça sera ça va être la même
chose pour le cas bien où ça va quand
même rester un produit un peu
d'exceptions témoin après en termes de
modes de consommation je pense que c'est
effectivement c'est plus fin déjà le
coût de revient réel et plus élevées
donc nous y voilà
de toute façon il ya un coup voilà donc
c'est quand même plus difficile d'élever
des esturgeons que des canards voilà et
les modes de consommation font que aussi
on va pas manger du caviar tous les
jours néanmoins je pense que tout ce qui
s'est passé sur la filière du saumon il
ya quelques années avec une dégradation
de la qualité et les scandales
sanitaires enfin tout
toutes ces approches de choses terribles
qui se sont passées sans une bonne leçon
pour des filières plus jeunes qui comme
celle du caviar d'élevage qui a une
vingtaine d'années
en gros enfin un peu plus longtemps mais
vraiment une vingtaine d'années et c'est
des bonnes leçons
c'est une bonne leçon puisque en fait
quand même on se rend compte ça sert à
rien de tirer les prix et de faire des
mauvais produits le terrain il se passe
rien enfin gère la filière s'effondrer
donc on a tous plutôt intérêt à
travailler main dans la main et à
promouvoir un super produit et avoir la
pédagogie pour le consommateur et le
faire découvrir
mais écoutez nous on essaye alors
apprécié les autres échelles non de tout
petit vous savez donc on est on est
petit mais je mets moi je vois avec
plaisir en tout cas dans notre boutique
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
aussi qu'on attire les jeunes oui voilà
parce que bon quand vous êtes jeune vous
avez moins d'argent en général mais
cette curiosité bon ces fameux millénium
qui les foodies dont qui a bien dépenser
de l'argent pour la nourriture qui sont
devant nous mais en fait c'est un vrai
un vrai plaisir
ils sont beaucoup au restaurant ils
dépensent pas mal d'argent et ils ont
plaisir à découvrir le caviar voyez donc
ça ces réseaux sociaux 6-1 sur la surca
bien sûr bien sûr et nous nous essayons
de promouvoir des modes de consommation
jeudi des coquillettes bon on va pas le
boire forcément avec de la vodka rhin
mon verre de vin blanc
ça fait la sphère du champagne si on est
riche ou un super bon crémant
ça fait la faire aussi donc il faut
sortir maintenant de caviar de cette
gangue si vous voulez de location
cristal de service
fiston cci bleuzé voilà voilà dans le
sahtu terre nouvelle eve on voit à
l'écran pas à la burrata au caviar
ça c'est un truc de dingue c'est dingue
vous prenez une bonne bourre à tort on
en trouve marie facilement d'un bon pas
grillé et l'a bien fait ça c'est génial
et vous le partagez vous ça vous fait
une entrée à partager de fêtes où un
apéro dînatoire comme tous même les
moins jeunes comme moi aujourd'hui on
aime bien faire ça vous mettez ça sur la
table des tarama voilà on voit bon nous
on essaie de ont fait déguster aussi dit
à la royale mons et les professionnels
qui déguste comme ça le caviar aux
poulets de tous comme ça c'est très
amusant
voilà pas de chichi vous vous régalez
c'est fun voilà vous passez à un bon
moment qu est-ce qu est-ce qui a déjà
mangé beaucoup de kalia ou me dois donc
au oui on aime ça quand même
quand même bien mais j'étais amusé par
les coquettes parce que je me dis moi
j'ai cinq enfants qui vont adorer la vie
ayant pour vous faire vous faites les
griller pour brûler des solutions mais
j'adore effectivement les enfants de
plus en plus surtout si on leur fait
goûter jeunes il reste pour la vie mais
moi j'ai trois enfants encore jeunes et
ils adorent felisa mieux gérer les
caprices à ce formidable vous amener un
peu de caviar
oui tout à fait elle constituait
l'événement peut parler d'un tout petit
peu de vous de votre parcours oui parce
que vous avez parfois assez incroyable
d'être normalienne oui je suis allé
exhumé mais mon mon cv d'accord oui oui
alors
en fait oui non moi je écoutez moi je
dors à susciter quelques sections en
lettres connaître en lettres oui donc
donc moi c'est vrai que bon je suis
quelqu'un d'assez passionné j'ai la
chance jusqu'à présent d'avoir fait tout
ce que j'avais envie de faire donc c'est
vrai que j'ai eu la chance d'avoir ce
concours extraordinaire de normale sup
en lettres donc ça ça ne se refuse pas
mais je savais donc se sauver voilà vous
avez la chance d'être reçu voilà donc
c'est extraordinaire bon voila moi
néanmoins je savais dès le départ que je
n'étais pas du tout fait pour l'ancien
vous dis pas non c'est moi je devais des
années j'ai signé donc j'ai enseigné un
petit peu et puis après je me suis
réorientée assez rapidement vers le
commerce à ces voix là et donc j'ai fait
le concours d'architecte en h ausse et
voilà à dachau c'est donc je connais
bien je suis content mais voilà et
franchement ça a été un choix génial que
je regrette pas du tout puisque ça m'a
permis
voilà de faire ce que ce que ce que
j'aime en fait c'est de travailler dans
des secteurs dont j'ai travaillé
longtemps dans le cosmétique voilà
l'oréal j'ai adoré faire ça et puis la
passion de l'alimentaire ça c'est quand
même une passion personnelle que je fais
depuis tout petit et je fais attention
on est obligé donc il faut compenser
mort quelques à bien ce n'est pas le
travail dans le chocolat gb qu'ils
occasionnent dans le caviar c'est bon
parce que vous avez des cdc qui lui
colle alors ça c'est le chocolat c'est
une autre histoire assez sur les grilles
de maigrir en mémoire après vous faites
avec là je me sens frais des arbitrages
entre le verre de vin le chocolat
dessert l'entrée et c'est donc ça c'est
dans un secteur qui est alors partie
clinique et qui appartiendrait au
secteur du luxe
oui oui absolument c'est un secteur qui
est qui qui représente bien la france
mais qui le sait
encore un des secteurs et même le
secteur peut-être qu'ils peuvent le
mieux aux france non c'est un secteur et
puis franchement sur la gastronomie de
luxe la france a une carte à jouer
extraordinaire enfin c'est
extraordinaire les produits tous les
produits que nous avons la gastronomie
au sens large le vin enfin c'est
aujourd'hui donc c'est un secteur
effectivement qui pèse lourd
économiquement et qui a des perspectives
de développement qui dont je considère
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui encore immense
et c'est vrai qu'on enquête dans
certains cas on peut manquer un peu de
dynamisme sur l'export de la
valorisation de nos produits
on va parler technologie dans un resto
avec vous d'abord tombé peut-être que
commencer michael par votre top parce
qu'on a parlé de gastronomie donc
maintenant il faut faire un peu d'effort
quelqu'un qui a fait un blessé votre top
on sport de la d1
c'est exactement mon top en sport de
l'année c'est du cyclisme sur piste
aujourd'hui je vous propose le portrait
d'un pistard qui a marqué 2019 quentin
lafargue le sportif licencié au vélo
club elancourt 50 ans neeve il a
remporté trois titres majeurs cette
saison des performances qui devrait
l'emmener aux jeux olympiques patrice
regardez ce reportage
quentin lafargue c'est l'histoire d'une
mécanique bien rodée le pistard a
commencé le vélo à l'âge de 12 ans dans
une école de cyclisme en gironde
c'était en 2003 sur le vélodrome de
bordeaux comme tous les jeunes j'ai vite
eu quelques résultats et
ça m'a surtout beaucoup plus toutes les
épreuves liées au sprint à la vitesse
j'avais un gabarit assez un corpulent
quand j'étais plus jeune et surtout plus
court plus corpulents que les autres et
du coup je prenais beaucoup de plaisir à
faire des disciplines de sprint
aujourd'hui quentin lafargue à 29 ans il
côtoie un autre vélodrome le national à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est ici que le sportif décroche ses
premiers résultats sur la scène
internationale en 2016 l'athlète
remporté l'or sur le km lors des
championnats d'europe en 2015 première
médaille sur un championnat du monde
avec le bronze en vitesse individuelle
c'était vraiment le dernier sprint du
championnat après moi ans ils ont éteint
les lumières presque donc voilà c'est
une vraie
enfin une vraie belle image montlaur
genre tiens énormément d'émotion et
voilà 6000 personnes qui crient pour te
faire pédaler un tout petit peu plus
vite c'est voilà je vous lirez jamais ça
2015 une année particulière mais 2019
restera une année unique pour quentin
lafargue le sportif a remporté cette
année trois titres trois médailles d'or
sur le kilomètre lors des mondiaux les
championnats d'europe et de france très
belle saison 2010 9 sur laquelle
physiquement j'ai montré que la
progression qu'on enfin suivait son
cours et est en tout cas qui donne
beaucoup de confiance pour la suite ça
faisait quelques années qui tournait
autour ont un peu autour du cou et je
dirais que cette année elle ait été
l'année de la consécration de de cantat
mais ça fait quand même quelques années
qu'on consent que planter un peu faire
des grands résultats
des résultats qui permettent à son
équipe le vélo-club elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines team vous sert
d'avoir un rayonnement international
quant à la fin car rejoint cette
structure en novembre 2018
c'est une fierté c'est une fierté c'est
exceptionnel c'est quelqu'un de humble
humble et porté vers la jeunesse
un exemple quentin lafargue espère
maintenant décrocher son billet pour les
jeux olympiques de tokyo l'année
prochaine en espérant que 2020 soit une
aussi belle année que 2019
c'est spectaculaire le thé green sur
piste les spectaculaires oui
effectivement c'est satisfaisant route
qui est vraiment beaucoup plus longs qui
est beaucoup plus dans dans l'endurance
mais pourquoi alors pour effet de la
piste il a commencé comme je disais en
reportage il a commencé par la rue mais
il avait un vélodrome juste à côté de
chez lui en fait du coup il a voulu à
tester tester la piste et et ça a marché
il
je suis dit là il a pu il a pu faire des
supers résultats il a continué ça veut
dire qu'ils feraient jamais le tour de
france normalement non il faudra pas le
tour de france
alors il y en a certains
de la piste et qui font le bret cyclisme
sur route ça dépend sodebo sprinteur
arrivé là par exemple
adrien gamal qui était au vélo-club
elancourt saint quentin en yvelines a
fait fait de la route
il est passé sur la piste et là il
revient sur la route il va notamment
faire paris roubaix par exemple et voilà
tout simplement il était sûr sur la
route sur la piste ça arrive que dès
qu'ils passent mais c est alors vous
dites il va être probablement
sélectionnés pour le jeux olympiques ça
servira pas loin alors il ya un petit
problème par contre c'est qu'il est
champion du monde du kilomètre et le
gros souci c'est que le kilomètre n'est
pas aux jeux olympiques ne l'est plus en
tout cas du coup il devrait être aux
jeux olympiques mais dans une autre
épreuve si ça serait la vitesse par
équipes d'accord ah oui papin en
solitaire si je veux dire justement
voilà il sera en équipe voilà d'accord
mais il aura pas loin puisque ce sera là
ou qui on traîne non alors tokyo dans un
premier temps et après ensuite les jeux
olympiques de paris sa serais peut-être
un peu rauque et autres mais par contre
les olympiques seront organisées ici au
biodôme de 51 à vivre normalement il
devrait alors il a 29 ans il vient
d'avoir 21 ans ça fait limite c'est
quand même assez limité j'ai un peu
limite mais il a pour projet bien sûr de
faire des jeux olympiques
ici à chez lui en fait d'accord alors on
reviendra tout à l'heure vous tombez
vous flop mais on va parler de
technologies avec le droit d'auto de xd
motion
alors peut-être hamou sur sept sur sept
entreprises
oui à la poignée on est à coignières
donc eczéma shawn est une société très
spécialisés on est expert dans un
dans une niche je dirai quelle est la
particularité de faire de la prise de
vue stabiliser je ne sais pas être trop
techniques mais en gros on équipe tous
les systèmes aériens donc qui vont de
l'avion l'hélicoptère les caméras sur
câble les rails avec les caméras qui
c'est ça c'est ça
voilà j'ai fait le premier match
pratiquement au monde de foot
ce qui était donc le france allemagne au
stade de france en février 2004 la
première utilisation d'une caméra qui
vient des états unis qui a utilisé
beaucoup sur football américain et donc
j'ai depuis 20 ans
développer tout ce savoir faire tout en
restant voilà entre on est un peu dans
l'industrie du luxe dans ce que l'on
fait dans notre prise de vue très
spécial dont green dans des activités
internationales assez forte dont les
jeux olympiques puisqu'on avait couvert
à londres le cyclisme de trédion le
cyclisme avec ce type de technologie et
donc au fur et à mesure des années j'ai
développé des technologies quasiment
unique qui fait appel à vous alors on a
quatre secteurs principaux
donc dans l'audiovisuel donc le cinéma
toute la partie long métrage donc on a
couvert j'ai couvert beaucoup de films
français en tant qu'opérateur moi même
puisque je suis spécialisé c'est mon
métier
donc le long métrage pour tous ces
couvertures le l'événementiel donc
concert tout ce qui est grande salle de
paris notamment et nous font appel ainsi
que des salles internationales
et puis beaucoup de sport c'est la
grosse activité l'entreprise donc les
jeux olympiques depuis pratiquement
albertville je découvre tous donc
donc on est spécialisé on a fait des
derniers à pyeong chang donc encore et
où j'ai découvert tous les sports
extrêmes avec notre technologie donc on
était 50 sur l'événement les ouvriers
voilà qui ont été utilisés sur ces
techniques là les coupes du monde ont
fêté comme une oasis games et les asian
games la champions league de foot en
france c'est probablement des domaines
où on a fait le plus de progrès dans la
prise de vue dans le passé
extraordinaire
en fait le sport et notamment les jeux
olympiques c'est un challenge permanent
c'est à dire qu'en fait les réalisateurs
et l'organisation des jeux olympiques
nous pousse toujours dans nos
retranchements donc il faut toujours
innover toujours aller plus loin j'ai
fait les premiers drones de prises de
vue aériennes sur sotchi donc en russie
c'était la première fois que ça va être
utilisé c'était un gros challenge sur le
soap stade qui était une nouvelle
le discipline donc de snowboard ski
spécifiques et c'est vrai qu'on nous
pousse très loin dans la technologie et
surtout que la qualité augmente donc
voilà c'est un facteur de sécurité aussi
qui est très important sur lequel on a
une grande expertise puisqu'en france il
faut savoir que le la réglementation
d'utilisation de ce type d'outil est la
plus ferme et la plus dure au monde il
ya plus difficile à un jour non risqués
dos des pauvres est possible parce que
je pense que ça en fait en fait ce qui
est ce qui est incroyable c'est tout
simplement la miniaturisation qui
aujourd'hui on est parti de deux choses
extrêmement lourdes et auto filmé en
mairie le football à l'arrière 70 g j'ai
vu il a aujourd'hui une américanisation
je m'active d'immersion vraiment
l'objectif dans le sport en l'occurrence
c'est d'être avec le sportif le plus
proche possible et donc d'avoir toutes
ses sensations vivre l'action quand on
filme par exemple cndd bolt
quand il faisait le j'ai pensé avec lui
quand il a démarré les sur paris 2003
sur les championnats du monde c'est vrai
que là on vit avec lui on est avec lui
cette caméra qui file à 10 mètres
secondes voilà on se rend vraiment
compte
nuon ans technicien de l'effort que le
sportif amène donc notre demande c'est
de tourner avec des moyens techniques le
plus proche possible et surtout montré
la technique du sport c'est ce qui est
important par exemple lorsque j'ai mis
la première fois le cas beckham sur le
sur le rugby sur les six nations qui
couvre au stade de france mais bien la
mêlée qui est prise par dessus nous ça
nous a permis de montrer la déformation
de la mêlée choses rien ne voyait jamais
envers un jour de souvenir ce qui se
passe alors j'ai beaucoup bossé avec
l'asie il y avait de la pelouse du stade
pour réaliser ça mais vous avez avoué
que les arbitres sont équipés déjà on
n'est pas très loin puisque aujourd'hui
des arbitres ont des caméras et les
melons et ils sont déjà équipés et
l'avare par exemple c'est vous pas marre
à ces panneaux c'est dommage d'être
mieux ça que que ça venait
oui je crois comme un petit clip sur eux
sur sur l'entreprise va regarder tout de
suite après il faisait beau choc
[Musique]
mais
m
[Musique]
incroyable parce que c'est vrai que là
on va maintenant l'association d'y être
coiffes à être cotées et même mieux
presque c'est un problème d'ailleurs
parce qu'on est presque mieux demander
que je vous avoue franchement que parent
je veux citer un exemple sur un concert
j'ai filmé jeu les revues en salles
n'est qu'en d'écran j'étais mieux les
apprécier le son la technique la qualité
d'image tout ce qu'ils étaient c'est
incroyable alors il ya quand même
l'ambiance se détend et c'est samedi ça
pour que c'est un pote mais non non mais
je pense que c'était assez amusant de
voir le concert et ensuite d'aller le
revoir en sache je pense que c'est un
lien différent si grossièrement on est
assez content de finalement vivre les
deux expériences meilleur c'est vrai
l'événement sportif on ne voit pas tout
à fait de la même façon selon que selon
qu'on est dans l'événement alors c'est
vrai quelle ambiance
mais c'est vrai que parfois on voit
mieux contre désormais quand après ils
déferlent les écrans intactes quand même
maintenant les matchs sportifs on voit
si notamment sur les matches de ligue 1
maintenant il ya des grands écrans oui
je les connais des stades voilà il ya
même dans les rues des statistiques dans
les loges les deux visions des écrans il
regarde parfois plutôt les croque
monsieur drop 6 au stade
alors moi ça fait trente ans que je suis
dans ce métier rien passionné je suis
opérateur de prise de vue donc c'est
véritablement l'essence même de mon
savoir faire et en fait j'ai recherché
des outils très spécifiques dont
certains j'ai fait un certain temps avec
vous
vous rappelez on a innové vous avez été
le premier à faire on avait une caméra
sur rails ont été les premiers au monde
sa légèreté des casinos et christophe
dechavanne aussi aussi quand j'étais sur
place et c'est vrai qu'on avait fait
c'étaient des débuts donc dans les
années 90 et à partir de là j'ai été
précurseur dans le drone puisque j'ai
fait des premières prises de vue drones
au monde dans les années 95 oui donc à
partir d'hélicoptères j'ai commencé à
faire des défilés de la partie à huis
clos des dicos d'hélico mais miniature
d'accélérer les caméras miniatures on a
vraiment on a vraiment en fait c'est
assez amusant puisque j'ai créé le poste
de pilote au sol n'existait pas en
france on a créé simple aux dires et
donc on est parti de cette technique et
ensuite je suis arrivé à donc avec mon
métier à travailler dans le monde entier
et j'ai fait des rencontres de beaucoup
d'ingénieurs de beaucoup de techniciens
etc
finalement chacun travaille dans son
coin et mon rôle a été finalement de les
exposer par rapport au marché et de
prendre cette technologie de les
utiliser
donc j'ai créé les propres outils à
coignières comme le câble comme le x
lite qui s'appelle chez nous en multis
dimension qu'il ya vraiment et le robot
qu'on verra tout à l'heure qui sont des
technologies très pointues et
spécifiques et et c'est finalement en
tant qu'artiste qui qui peut peindre une
toile
il nous faut des outils pour soirée ben
finalement j'ai créé où j'ai recherché
les outils adaptés et ce qui est assez
amusant c'est que en rencontrant les
réalisateurs du monde entier puisque les
jeux olympiques il veut retravailler
pour le monde entier
finalement c'est un enrichissement
exceptionnel c'est à dire de pouvoir
avoir ses demandes vous les montre des
choses il peut faire ça dans la vie
jurassic park en 360° avec 32 caméras à
hawaï installé sur la caméra sur câble
ça a été pour moi un challenge énorme de
travailler dans des techniques sur un
volcan est en pleine jungle ou tournée
des mascaret
en fin fond de l'amazonie avec des
équipes d'hélicoptères hystérique qui
sont extrêmement pointus donc c'est
toujours des challenges techniques
la grosse difficulté c'est qu'il faut
mettre tout le monde en sécurité parce
qu'il faut aussi être conscient que
quand on est au stade de france on vole
au dessus de 80 mille personnes plus les
joueurs donc c'est pas une pression
importante aussi donc tout ce mélange la
créer je dirais un mélange de métier
qu'on ait notre expertise et j'adore ça
donc c'est j'ai voyagé je pense que sa
politique
on est impatient on peut dire c'est un
film chez vous exceptionnel et raconter
votre fils votre image ou même dans
toutes les activités
il ya des fois où la trouille a alors il
faut de toute façon je pense que ça
c'est vrai pour tous les métiers il faut
la voir parce que c'est ça la sécurité
si vous n'avez pas c'est bien contre il
faut il faut le maîtriser je pense que
c'est comme un alpiniste mon pénis il
est toujours un ou deux degrés en
dessous de son maximum s'il n'est pas
accroché il va pas aller au maximum s'il
accroché il va dépasser ses limites mais
en général ils essayent quand même pas
d'aller au-delà et de risquer sa vie
on est dans l'extrême nous ce qu'on leur
en fait c'est l'extrême permanent et de
l'innovation et donc la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est que les clients on
trouve ça très facile à faire et donc il
nous donne des délais de plus en plus
courts pour les réaliser et pour nous la
difficulté reste toujours entière donc
c'est ce qui est c'est ce qu'on doit
maîtriser au quotidien le plus compté
pour vous tournage le plus compliqué ça
a été l'introduction de vladimir poutine
au kremlin ou en fait ils nous ont
simplement demandé de danser les câbles
au dessus du kremlin sur un kilomètre de
long là j'avoue que entre toutes les
normes de sécurité d'accès de techniques
liées à cet événement ça a été un énorme
énorme challenge pour la société je sais
que cette dernière élection on a fait
les deux dernières qui ont on a utilisé
on a utilisé une fois au dessus du
kremlin en deux dimensions donc la
caméra pour descendre et on l'a utilisé
deux fois 1 km devant kremlin en
utilisation et c'est vrai que c'était
dans des contraintes d'un pays qui ne
suit pas forcément les réglementations
que l'on grille en a en europe une
difficultés aussi à maîtriser toutes les
normes de sécurité et de l'exil est
exigée par an vous êtes notre domaine
vous être des leaders ont écouté en tout
cas un expert c'est sûrement dans ce que
l'on réalise ces niches on est on est
peut-être cinq au monde à ce niveau là
donc on est peu nombreux
vous connaissez tous on se connaît tous
on s'apprécie beaucoup et on travaille
ensemble
il m'a choisi un service voilà j'ai moi
je suis assez moderne danse et moi
j'aime bien être avec mes concurrents
donc je trouve que c'est pas travailler
compte ces voix là on a chacun nos
marchés en fonction
on aime bien aussi s'entraider et je
trouve que ça fait avancer le métier
puis de façon plus y en a plus y en aura
de travail donc et c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
alors on parlait de la miniaturisation
des moyens techniques
ici par exemple votre foi il y avait des
quatre heures il ya plus de quatre
heures dans la plupart des studios de
télé d'aujourd'hui le prochain la
prochaine étape c'est leur boulot
voilà donc en fait c'est parfait exemple
ce studio de ce qui se passe c'est
qu'aujourd'hui toute cette émission est
filmé avec des petites remote l'on
appelle des ptz et ces caméras sont donc
télécommande est entièrement et
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'avoir un peu
de mouvement par rapport à ces caméras
et en fait il existe des robots
industriels qui sont utilisés notamment
dans les yvelines chez technocentre
renault ou autre est en fait ce sont des
robots industriels avec des outils qui
permettent de souder des carrosseries
nous l'idée que nous avons mis en place
sur ce projet là c'est de remplacer
l'outil par une caméra
donc c'est un robot six axes qui en fait
si je pour l'expliqué très simplement
c'est votre bras tout simplement elle
avait six axes comme moi vous avez un
poignet un coude une épaule et donc le
système se déplacent c'est ce que vous
voyez là rien donc il acquis la capacité
d'être
d'emporter 10 kg de charge utile une
caméra est donc ce studio ce pardon ce
robot a été utilisé dans les studios
pour justement faire un mouvement
permanent large pour donner une certaine
aération sur les plans ambiance toujours
fixé c'est pas toujours fixé donc on
l'utilisent pour faire des mouvements
répétés des mouvements fonctionnel et
donc tout ça est géré par un logiciel et
ce logiciel peut gérer également toutes
les caméras que vous avez sur studio ici
jusqu'à 20 caméras pratiquement entre le
robot trois robots vingt caméras et
sousse a géré par une personne
donc on a la possibilité de faire ce
type de d'applications hélas bien
l'hiver de mon père des enfants voilà
nord parce que moi je resterai d'autres
emplois moi j'en crée ont effectivement
c'est en plus c'est vraiment une forte
demande vous voyez bien aussi en
sécurité le ce type de caméra et tout ce
que ça a créé comme comme emploi là on
vient d'être rappelé par les états unis
notamment sur baseball pour utiliser ce
genre de technique sur les stades donc
on est bien dans des supporters voilà
donc on peut on peut aussi exporter ce
type de technologie ce qui est pour moi
une grande fierté aussi c'est que tous
mes produits sont fabriqués en france et
donc j'essaye véritablement de les
exporter sous là sous la bannière
française etc voilà c'est une certaine
fierté que j'ai de ces faits dans l'île
en ile-de-france s'accrochèrent non
alors justement comme ce robot
formidable c'est ça qui est formidable
c'est qu'elle est dictée ici aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que c'est important
d'avoir cette expertise si aujourd'hui
je devais fabriquer ce robot je pourrais
pas c'est impossible
mail avantage c'est que c'est comme ces
dérivés de l'industrie
il les fabrique à des milliers
d'exemplaires donc une fois que vous
avez donc une économie d'échelle dans
son ensemble de production c'est tout à
fait accessible et c'est pour ça qu'on
en rencontre un fort succès bien sûr il
faut le rendre stable possible pour ce
qu'on appelle le broadcast dans
l'utilisation mai
voilà il ya 10 me dis que les
modifications qu'on est obligé
d'apporter mais ça reste vertement un
outil très accessible pour les chefs des
divisions et d'où l'intérêt de
l'utiliser de plus en plus et vous allez
former puisqu'on des yéyés des écoles de
audiovisuel millions les yvelines
vous allez former d'aider des jeunes
avec ça alors je vais vous dire quelque
chose qui est totalement incroyable
c'est que j'arrive pas à recruter
donc je passe un appel vraiment
aujourd'hui se jure c'est incroyable on
fait le média combien de votre alors
nous on est ce à six permanents et on a
cinquante intermittents c'est régulier
chez nous et en fait on n'arrive pas à
recruter depuis presque deux ans en
technique
alors c'est vrai qu'il faut se lever tôt
on doit partir à trois heures du matin à
la belle lumière faire des tournages
extra c'est vrai qu'on parle moins on a
des missions mais c'est juste
exceptionnel
donc c'est à dire voilà c'est incroyable
donc l'idée on en a parlé avec donc tv
78 telle qu'on essaye de mettre en place
c'est que je me suis dis bah finalement
coignières par rapport au plateau on est
juste à côté on a le robot nous on a
besoin aussi de faire des évolutions de
son histoire
certaines scènes et on est on a
plusieurs écoles d'ingénieurs
audiovisuelle qui sont dans le
décideront voilà donc on s'est dit tous
naturellement mais pourquoi ne pas
former ces jeunes éliront il faut quelle
formation
alors en fait s'arrête tout ce qui va
être machinerie spécialisation dans
l'audiovisuel l'idée est venue en fait
finalement d'une école étrangère
hollandaise qui est leader dans ce type
de match d'un ricky m'ont contacté et
qui ont acheté mon robot pour former des
jeunes et je me suis dit mais pourquoi
finalement cette école en landes le fait
et pas nous donc automatiquement j'ai
proposé donc à la chaîne et puis je
pense dans les semaines qui viennent on
va en parler avec les différentes écoles
pour donner accès à ses technologies qui
sont ultra innovante pour former nos
futurs opérateurs qui pourront non
seulement travaillé chez nous travailler
chez vous et puis aussi se former et
développer ses technologies parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne trouve pas
deux personnes c'est pas ne sont pas
intéressés mais il faut faire passer ce
texte est publié
il faut faire passer de l'intérieur
formation 2 500 patients trouvent pas de
gens qui est notamment dans les métiers
de bouche parce que c'est difficile
non mais c'est vrai que c'est des
métiers parfois compliqué avec niveau
effectif mais mais mais bon faire des
images saisies en bresse de ça non voilà
il faut une certaine
alors il faut discipliner il faut je
pense que les jeunes ont une passion
véritable lorsque l'on fait il imagine
pas toutes les possibilités sont très
agréablement surpris là par exemple on a
quand même signé c'est nous qui allons
réaliser tous les drones pour les jeux
olympiques donc de tokyo et les jeux
olympiques de la jeunesse et ont vendu à
lausanne en janvier donc c'est vrai que
voilà c'est venant des yvelines partir
comme ça sur tokyo avec des moyens comme
cela allait filmer le surf avec des
drones sur jeux olympiques je sais pas
je devrais avoir une liste d'attentes à
mon avis deux kilomètres donc je lance
un appel
il faut pas hésiter à nous contacter
véritablement c'est un besoin je serai
ravi de faire partager ma passion
qu'est-ce qui comme c'est quelqu'un il
faut si on a une formation si on n'a pas
de formation aux vidéos sur mais
qu'était la formation dans les écoles
comme troisième oui il ya des écoles
sont minables
par exemple quelqu'un qui voudrait
qu'une formation à leurs potes l'heure
actuelle moi spécialement opérateurs de
prise de vues et plus mécatronique
électronique ingénieurs
ça peut être une formation tout ce qui
est lié à l'électricité l'électronique
la mécanique
il n'y a pas de limite marc pour ça
alors il ya un gros problème en dehors
de la motivation qui est obligatoire
c'est quand même la langue bien
évidemment il veut avoir un anglais
courant et parce que forcément
mais la plaie travail est appelé à
travailler et des réserves qui est au
minimum en anglais voilà bah c'est
génial non c'est génial
et ben oui quoi optique nos petits tops
et des flops
enfin petite histoire incroyable on
retrouve voilà handicaperait avis là
c'était en mars dernier le front cocu
bandits cabreira ville a réalisé un
nouveau record à la piscine de saint cyr
l'école après avoir nagé en apnée
dynamique pendant six heures et 12
heures
cette fois ci il a respiré écoutez bien
4 minutes 12 en six heures en apnée
statique 4 minutes 12
un défi qu'il s'est lancé pour dénoncer
la maltraitance des animaux marins dans
les parcs aquatiques
voilà il a l'habitude vraiment de voilà
on voit à l'écran 15 minutes à six
minutes 12 secondes en six heures et
comme nous fait alors en fait il prenait
juste sa respiration une respiration
il se remettait dans l'eau et il a fait
ça c'est de dire qu'il reste cependant
si jeanne d'heure sans respirer c'est un
donc je veux dit des bêtises il nous
prend plus une respiration minutes en
six tableaux c'est une minute trente
deux minutes il prend une respiration et
il se remet donc vers un exploit il a
l'habitude des voyages a fait dès 6
heures dès 12h aussi d'apnée mais plus
avec avec plus de mouvement alors je
surveillais parce qu'ils avaient
paula de granger comme ça qui compte est
un tueur en série qui était un apnéiste
et justement il puis c'est parce qu'ils
le faisaient les empêcher de respirer et
oui il s'en fichait complètement parce
qu'il pouvait comme de votre avis
geovanni le surveiller le quand même
voilà le surveiller il a une histoire
comme casser particulière il est passé
de cuba très jeune il ay l'affût cuba
pour arriver en france
il se retrouve à la piscine aqua mundo
de saint cyr l'école et finalement voilà
il saignait à la fne petit à petit et il
a concédé record est juste peugeot alors
alors julie peugeot alors ça c'est un
peu plus insolites
bon ça n'était déjà pas mal sur un
handicap mais julie peel joueurs donc
c'est une plaisir oise de 30 ans elle a
remporté cet été le concours de miss
sirène france et oui vous avez bien
entendu ces disciplines il est dit et
original mélange à la fois le sport et
la beauté objectif retenir sa
respiration encore une fois avec un
costume de sirène voilà comme vous voyez
alors remporté cette épreuve face à huit
candidates et c'est un vrai sport car
s'entraîne plusieurs fois par semaine à
la piscine les clayes-sous-bois et
maintenant enchaîner également et là
elle à retenir sa respiration une minute
trente deux minutes c'est pas encore une
discipline olympique non ce n'est pas au
crâne discipline olympique
et surtout pourquoi amnesty que ça va
dans le mur il termine s'était imaginé
le carnaval la piscine
intronisé mercredi ce serait joli nom
d'etienne arrêtera film et c'est
exceptionnel en tout cas un film ici et
puis peut-être on peut leur donner des
costumes d'esturgeon on va peut-être
parler avec ses dynamiques ou alors vous
êtes c'est un titre assez tôt
fournisseuse de bonheur en entreprise et
vous êtes évidemment vous c'est quoi une
fournisseuse de bonheur en entreprise
alors le bonheur ne s'impose pas il se
cultive au quotidien donc je mets en
place des solutions 'gagnant-gagnant'
avec les
les entreprises et les salariés
l'entreprise a besoin de salariés
motivés pour être rentable l'étude
montre cela et les salariés plutôt que
de dire vivement vendredi
le but c'est de dire vivement lundi
qu'on se retrouve et de leur donner
envie de venir travailler les uns avec
les autres
donc le concept doping causé une journée
de formation ou deux selon les besoins
et les envies de chacun ou à l'issue de
laquelle les employés prennent un
engagement sur comment ils vont cultiver
leur bonheur au quotidien et j'aurais
intervient une demi journée tous les
trois mois pour voir
ok ce que vous aviez décidé est ce que
c'est en place est-ce que vous avez
besoin c'est quoi le bonheur alors
empêché chacun parlait parce que vous
savez que c'est très contestée ça y est
beaucoup plus d'eux qu'ils disent et s2
et bidau que de dire que l'on va trouver
le bonheur c'est dépend de votre
environnement ça dépend de ce qui se
passe autour de vous si vous avez
quelqu'un de très malade dans votre dans
votre entourage vous le bonheur vous le
trouverez pas alors c'est quoi le
bonheur alors vous c'est un peu
différent passé le bonheur en entreprise
1 c'est ça mais avant chaque
intervention j'envoie un questionnaire à
chaque participant pour demander ce
qu'elle est sa définition du bonheur
puisque on a autant de définitions du
bonheur que de personnes autour de la
table si je vous demandais quel était
votre définition du bonheur qu'est ce
que vous pourriez me répondre moi oui je
veux dire je ne sais pas oui ça c'est le
plaisir le plaisir c'est pas le beurre
le plaisir je vois ce que c'est non mais
et c'est un des problèmes du bonheur
c'est que on voit très bien ce que c'est
de ne pas être malheureux être heureux
on le voit ce nom je sais pas et à
travers les réponses des participants à
ces ateliers
on regarde ce qu'ils ont en commun
puisque on se rejoint autour de valeurs
communes de sens commun et voir un petit
peu comment on peut faire caisse alors
je m'adapte complètement aux
personnalités
qui sont en équipe et puis si on n'a
plus besoin de bien-être de massage ça
peut être aussi merci ça ça passe par
des choses très concrètes la carte c'est
on a un menu mais ça peut dire qu'on
crée en fait c'est un sens concret ce
que s'est passé pas c'est pas une
spéculation philosophique justement ça
parce qu'on a besoin de massage d'être
mieux assise d'être je sais pas mieux
considérer d'être et puis ça peut passer
aussi par de l'art thérapie pour une
entreprise qui veut faire émerger des
valeurs et faire un totem de cette de
cette entreprise réunir autour
en ce moment c'est beaucoup d'écologie
de faire des jardins partagés de
s'inscrit dans le cadre et reste de
l'entreprise
est-ce que c'est au fond de créer une
sorte de deux communautés de cohésion de
cohésion ou de cohésion plutôt oui à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise c'est ça
aussi c'est ça c'est c'est faire de la
cohésion et voir ce qu'on a en commun
plutôt que de voir le côté français
râleurs ce qui ce qui ne va pas voir
plutôt le côté de ce qui va et le maître
justement en exergue leur en parle
beaucoup de 2 du balèze justement du
burn out
il breakait de plus en plus dans le
monde du travail
est-ce que c'est aussi une façon de
prévenir ce genre de deux choses où
est-ce que c'est trop individuel sa peau
pour au pays faire quelque chose alors
prévenir le bernard louis puisque quand
on a une équipe soudée
en principe on arrive à s'appuyer les en
avaient contre les autres travailler
avec
avec les autres et donc la personne qui
commence un burn out on peut s'en
apercevoir et puis un peu la soulager
voire qu'est ce qu'on peut mettre en
place plus rapidement avant d'arriver
jusque jusqu'au berne a déjà eu des cas
comment comment vous est venue l'idée de
créer ce gel autre trader d'autres pris
si longtemps travaillé en entreprise et
je me suis j'adorais rendre le sourire
le matin à mes collègues par le petit
déjeuner par des animations un petit peu
fun décalé qu'il était donc c'est ce qui
me faisait vibrer et j'ai dit pourquoi
ne pas juste
au lieu de le faire pour une entreprise
le diffuser à plusieurs entreprises et
puis ben rendre des gens heureux c'est
ce qui me fait vibrer donc c'est ce que
j'avais vraiment envie de faire et je
m'éclate
c'est une passion et vos clients c'est
plutôt des grandes entreprises et des
autres réseaux royal alors ça peut être
des grandes entreprises dans le cadre
parfois difficile de réorganisation sur
certaines équipes ça peut être aussi
après une vague de licenciements quand
il faut re motiver les personnes qui
sont restés et qui se disent c'est quand
mon tour couleur dit dans ce cas là il
faut les re motiver alors après ça
dépend de ceux des besoins et des deux
ce cas l'entreprise
et puis des participants c'est vraiment
personnel va rivaliser s'est vraiment
passé du sur mesure à chaque rêve d'y
accéder des autres tiens un individuel
ou alors non il ya tout un questionnaire
avant intervention que je traite et
après l'intervention effet en
partenariat avec l'entreprise et avec
les salariés en fonction des besoins des
deux ont réuni le gagnant gagnant et
puis les salariés j'avais remarqué une
grotte de leur part parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de formations ou de deux choses
qui sont mises en place dès team
building c'est juste une journée une
fois et puis après on oublie
sauf que là c'est un suivi sur l'anglais
donc on essaie un peu nos mécaniciens
qui en donnerait des outils ont trouvé
comment ben voila voila des outils je te
montre comment ont réparé la voiture et
puis au revoir
maintenant ils sont obligés d'utiliser
les outils et puis on fait un point
donc si ils ont effectivement pris des
engagements et qu'ils ont le bonheur de
venir travailler ensemble tous les
matins tant mieux on rajoute d'autres
choses s'ils ont besoin d'outils
supplémentaires japon des outils
supplémentaires tous les trois mois
françoise boisseau et côtoie de caviar
dont savaria pas pour le sto sait jamais
oui oui après moi je pense que ce qu'il
faut enfin nous notre philosophie c'est
plutôt de travailler avec du sens quoi
la fierté fait la fierté de ce qu'ont
fait donc comme vous le dites très bien
enfin genou on est super contents de
venir travailler tous les matins parce
que pierre vous avoir exprimé même à
plus grande échelle poids lourds entre
guillemets par rapport au nombre de
téléspectateurs sur le quai en touche et
transmettre du bonheur c'est aussi cette
émotion c'est je pense que s'est donnée
un peu au fond pendant la définition
c'est transmettre données et pas
uniquement recevoir je pense que c'est
aussi on reçoit en ayant donné je pense
que c'est c'est la règle qu'on essaie de
l'humainement se se mettre en place et
on fait aussi un travail autour des
valeurs de l'entreprise parce que
certaines entreprises ont des valeurs
intrinsèques mais ne le ne communique
pas à l'extérieur des valeurs donc on
fait aussi beaucoup de travail sur les
valeurs de l'entreprise et le sens du
travail et de ceux des salariés
michael almy d'euros très vite parce
qu'il nous reste plus beaucoup d'entre
elles vous aviez un flop
un flop oui c'était l'open de france de
golf cette édition du régime des
faillites était un peu triste un
l'européenne tour les organisateurs
avaient décidé de placer le penser ça
voilà seulement 24 mille deux cents
personnes se sont déplacées sur
l'événement contre 48 milles sur les
dernières éditions mois d'octobre n'est
pas vous c'est ça
moi je vois mais un travail commun à
trèbes au cannet gagnant avec cole
certes ce qui est belge franco belge qui
a gagné mais aussi dominateur ne s'y
sont pas retrouvés on va dire au niveau
des au niveau des chiffres
à tel point que l'open de france
pourraient être délocalisés
ce n'est pas encore officiel et dans le
sud de la france soit la règle d'or doit
d'antan vous filmer le duff
oui oui j'en ai fait sur l'open j'étais
un peu en colère parce qu'effectivement
on était juste à 500 mètres donc on n'a
rien pu mettre en place parce que ça a
été géré directement par l'organisation
et ça c'est un problème c'est l'épaule
donc c'est vrai qu'a remis dans leur
abaya voilà sur l'european tour donc
c'est vrai que je vois là je pense qu'il
ya déjà un travail à faire sur sur la
coordination aussi dans chaque pays
la raideur pourquoi non j'ai pas le
ravisseur ryder cup mais on a fait
d'autres tournois et c'est vrai que à
evian notamment féminine très beau temps
oui mais en attendant d'alain exactement
très c'est un magnifique et le tournoi
il faut un peu se creuser la tête ou pas
quand on filme du golfe c'est alors
c'est un des sports pas forcément
beaucoup à la télématique et en fait je
sais pas si vous imaginez les opérateurs
qui suivent les les balles de golf
mais nous on arrive à le faire d'avion
donc ces fours disait qu'il fallait pour
les cadreurs étaient des types qui
jouait extrêmement mis au golf au niveau
des handicaps très bas parce qu'ils
étaient les seuls à pouvoir suivre une
blessure ça change hélas oui on a en
plus les les voilà comment s'appellent
les tous les graphiques qui permettent
aujourd'hui les analyses qui aujourd'hui
et c'est ce que l'on fait notamment avec
toute la robotisation et nos systèmes
c'est ce que l'on appelle à arrêter
augmentée qui vient aussi se rajouter
sur toutes ces images
qui sont pas toujours faciles à
apercevoir par le grand public si elles
sont pas un peu ralenti ou décortiqué
par des graphiques qui permet de les
aider à animer un peu plus facilement il
faut créer le spectacle voilà alors je
sais pas si vous aimez la musique je
vais vous offrir c'est le centre de
musique baroque ajout voilà deux idées
de cadeaux c'est ça c'est un contre
contre-ténor on connait jaroussky et du
très très bon contre été menacé le
centre 2002 musique baroque et puis un
peu baroque pardon et puis raul barbe
bleue aussi voilà deux idées de cadeaux
si vous aimez bien la musique
merci infiniment françoise boisseau
merci sedin à mios merci benoît d'antan
et merci michael et demi d'euros et puis
bonnes fêtes à tous ça me fait
[Musique]